so one thing i want to talk to you about
juan is like you're like one of the
trailblazers in so many ways like you
went and carved this incredible
uh path for yourself um you eventually
come out as homosexual and it sounded
like that was a difficult process
because your family was quite
conservative
not you're married a beautiful family 11
year old twins
um and and then you were a writer
uh on roseanne and like they had this
this issue where
obviously like that like roseanne ended
up um
having some uh terrible statements that
came out on
twitter and then i believe you left that
show um
but on the same time like i see your
comedy and your comedy is so real
like your comedy is like no punches
being pulled like wanda sykes is like
you know just
like telling it like it is be real and
there's so many comedians from your era
that uh have issues with the fact that
it seems like the
uh the goalposts keep moving for comedy
or the goalposts keep moving for
art generally where like if artists were
to talk about certain things
x years ago we'd all be like yeah that's
fine um but now it seems like the
rules have shifted and and you again are
like one of the original trailblazers
uh of the era you've seen and done it
all like do you have a take on whether
cancel culture is um like
uh like at the right place a little bit
overboard still more work to be done
you know i i go back and forth on that
it
to me it's it's it's up to the audience
the audience gets to decide who's
canceled and who's
and who's not um i mean we can all say
hey that's wrong this person this person
should you know should go away or be
canceled
but if that person you know
says hey i'm doing a show and people and
the audience shows up and buys and
buys tickets to see that person
then who are we to say you know you're
wrong that you
you're not allowed to you know to to to
support or
this is the comic that you like you no
no we're not going to allow
allow this to happen if that person is
not for you
then fine then don't don't go see them
don't go support them
but yeah i don't i'm not for
somebody does one thing wrong and then
we banish them
well particularly in comedy and i just
as a human being too and as a
presidential candidate i can share
this uh you stick a mic in my face often
enough like eventually i'll say
something really stupid
you know that that's just humanity like
absolutely
and as a candidate like that there was
very much that dynamic
where people it almost seems like
they're trying to get you to say
something
problematic so they can be like see look
at this person and look at this
statement
and so that they'll like ask you
questions that you could tell are meant
to try and like
get a rise out of you or somewhat like
contentious and then
like as a candidate you had to
essentially just like
just check any kind of humanity at the
door in terms of like
an emotional response because if you
react emotionally then it's like oh
like then like we got him because
he reacted harshly when we like subtly
insinuated that he was
you know like a racist or a terrible
person or whatever the insinuation was
um and so so i understood at least that
part of it
as a candidate it's like like okay i get
it
but like if you catch anyone on film and
like their worst moments like we'd all
look freaking terrible
um you know like just as human beings
and so then if you say it's like look i
have this
this moment of this person saying
something regrettable um so let's try
and expunge their existence from
you know like the culture or from the
from social media or whatnot
but what you said initially to me was
like the way it used to be which is like
hey i don't like your art i don't like
your comedy so i will not watch or
consume it and i will just
turn it this way yeah does that make
sense i mean
that made sense to me yeah but but now
there's like a new thing it's like i
don't like what you're saying
and now i will somehow condemn you i
will somehow
try and tell others that like if you're
associated with this person
there's another part of it too that like
that there's like this um
strange supposed to be like transferal
of attitudes or beliefs like if if you
said something that
i disagreed with and i sat and had this
conversation with you then
i'm also actually in the wrong because
like i'm going to somehow be either
getting your
attitudes and beliefs from you or
somehow like
helping you transfer them to um to
others and it's like
can people just have a conversation and
like not like imagine that
uh i agree with everything that the
other person is
saying i mean happens in real life all
the time like you know i talk to my
neighbor my neighbor thinks
all sorts of stuff that i'm probably not
a fan of but it's like
you know i'd like to still talk over the
fence and you know like
no no problems were had um
so i i'm with with you on that level
it's like the
the negation of your own consumption
like
a okay but then like the negation of
anyone's consumption
it's like come on people should be able
to uh to see what they want to see
right i mean in your case it's more
complicated too for the fact that you
actually know a lot of people as human
beings and there's like a natural
temptation if you know someone as a
human being you'd be like oh like i know
that person
that's like a human being sometimes you
know the human being you're like oh that
person is an
yeah and then other times you'd be like
that person's actually okay that was
just some really dumb thing
um you know i wish we had a finer way to
distinguish between those two situations
you you can see it you can you can see
the
but where people that people don't come
to the to their defense
really really is that the way it is yeah
everybody's like uh-huh
okay finally got him but when
when people come out and say like hey
come on that guy's not like that
oh come on she's this person is a good
person that
and i then you know it's like okay come
on this
somebody just made a slip it's cool
leave them alone yeah
well that that's encouraging wanda well
you know we should definitely
like you know take a beat and look
around and be like can anyone uh
come to this person's different right
right because if so like we all just
like wait a day to like decide
whether i think um that i mean i could
be like at least
an improvement over the current process
i mean in an ideal world and this this
happens to me too an ideal world you'd
actually
like this is not realistic but it's the
ideal you'd actually just be able to
call a person up and be like hey so
what's up like what was that about
like here what the back story was of
course we never had that opportunities
and
and a lot of the time someone's career
is on the line so then they'll end up
having like a very
like rehearsed crafted statement and the
the rest of it um which in some ways is
really unfortunate because you kind of
want someone to be like all right like
you know this was the deal yeah exactly
the ones that are so crafted well
crafted they
they feel so fake and
you know the person is just saying it to
try to save their
career you know and this then you're
like nah
this is not this is not going to do it
but
i would rather for somebody to say
something if they say something
you know stupid or whatever racist
whatever
and they get called out on it for them
to go wait man what's what
was wrong with what i said you know i
rather for them to start at that point
like
what was wrong with it so at least now
people are saying well because it's this
this and they go oh oh
well i didn't think that but okay i can
see it that way okay my bad man
i'm sorry i won't you know at least
you're you're you see that there's a
there's some growth there they're
learning something but
um don't apologize if you don't know
what you're apologizing for
there there are parallels to politics
again with this because
you see also like the very very polished
statements
where like you know someone misspeaks
and there's a gaffe and then it's like
oh
like i'm i'm really really sorry and
like here are like the
things i mean this happened to me on the
trail too where you know like i was
accused of doing something
and then um these consultants are on my
campaign team were like all right you
need to apologize for this immediately
and i was like do you want to ask me
whether
this actually happened or whether like
there's a real thing you want to check
on that
and then then after they checked with
eventually so when i said that
they were like is this real and i was
like it is not
real and apologizing for it is like the
opposite
of what we should do because it happens
to be completely untrue
and like i got the sense too that the
consultants just assumed it was true
because probably they've been around
other situations where it was true
was probably it um but but also like
that's like their knee-jerk reaction
because they're like trying to protect
the um they're trying to protect like
the
institution or the franchise you know
like in this case it was like hey i was
a candidate it raised millions of
dollars they're getting paid
um uh by me and i didn't have that many
consultants because i really
disliked consultants um but we had a
couple
for uh media stuff and some other things
and so when they came up with this
guidance
like they're just trying to protect the
franchise and
and meanwhile they didn't even check
with a human being uh to be like hey
like
what's going on if we could somehow
humanize these communications
and do what you just suggested where the
person's like what's wrong with what i
said like can someone explain to me like
where i went wrong and then
you know have like a little bit more of
like a human education process
because like there's like a real
um there's like faux shame uh you know
you can sense it in some of these
communications
and it's preceded by this faux outrage
where it's like
like are people that like actually like
upset by what this person said like half
the time it that
someone says around you casually like
you know but they're not a public figure
obviously it's just some you know some
knucklehead like
like says it around you and like you
don't go around like you know
um like berating like uh
you know your freaking like uncle or
grandfather or whatever it happens to be
um and so that like there's this like so
there's like a faux
outrage and it like rises up and then
there it's followed by like this faux
penance or a faux shame and it's like
you know i will
think i will reflect i'll retreat into
my cave i will you know do it do the
stuff
it's like you know we need to like tap
both of those reactions down
ideally oh absolutely
yeah the the fake anger the fake that
just bugs me you know that oh it's just
the worst because it's like i know you
don't give a about this but
you just you just feel like you're this
is how you're the
the right way i should react you know um
but really what's so ridiculous
about all of this is that
trump has said some of the most the
craziest
ever craziest the most offensive
ever i mean grandma by the i
mean
if you start there and he still became
president
so it seems like everybody should get at
least three
we should all get like just three you
get
you you can you can say whatever crazy
you want to say three times and
nobody can message
thank you for listening in i hope you
enjoyed this conversation
if you did please do subscribe to yang
speaks and click on notifications so we
can let you know
every time we have a new episode
you